[Music]
do you swear to god the nine realms
i swear and do you swear
to preserve the peace i swear
one of the early decisions we made at
marvel studios was bringing on thor and
we always knew he wanted to find an
amazing performer who had the chops to
perform this character as we saw him
we looked the world over
and we found chris hemsworth this world
is my punishment
it's my punishment for my endless
pursuit of glory the way chris did it we
thought okay this is gonna work
it's really really just impressive to
watch him work he's so committed and
works so hard he has such incredible
comedic talent as well
just drink i like it another
not the best you can do
chris hemsworth
this is what it's all about you know
it's coming
meeting the people who love the
characters more than anyone and so
that's a very very special thing
[Music]
it really is inspiring because he is
brave enough to try things and see what
sticks
when i came home to do ragnarok i
basically said look and you just got to
be more of yourself
to make the character more relatable and
funny i swear i'm not even moving it's
just doing this on itself i think that's
what you wanted a superhero yeah
i have loved every single time i played
the character this is 10 years now to
have the opportunity to do another one
it's just mind-blowing you know it's
going to be incredible what a classic
forward venture
and flick
oh you flick too hard dammit
[Music]